So, Charles, I kind of cheated.
>> Oh, tell me more.
>> So, Q-learning isn't really an
algorithm. Q-leaning is actually a family of
algorithms. There's lots of different reinforcement learning
algorithms, specific reinforcement learning algorithms that can
be reasonably called Q-learning, and they
vary typically along these three dimensions. How
do we initialize our estimate, Q hat, how do we decay our learning rates,
alpha sub-t? And how do we choose actions during learning?
>> Hm.
>> And different ways of making
these choices actually lead to algorithms with
fairly different behaviors. In particular when we use this in the context of
an MDP, well let's, let me, let me ask you. So like, what
do you think might matter about let's start with the last one, choosing actions?
>> Well. It see, well there's a bunch of dumb
things you could do, right? You could just, just pick an
amption, action, action every single time, like the same action every single
time independent of what you learned, that's kind of dumb. But,
it seems like the obvious smart thing to do is say look,
I'm learning, I'm getting better and better, so what I'm going to
do is at this next time steps is I actually have to
take an action. I'll just pick the action that my Q
hat tells me is the best action to take. And I'm done.
>> So all right, let me, let me see if I can capture some of what you
just said there. So, one way to choose actions
really badly is say, pick some action, call it a
sub 0. And no matter what state your in.
No matter what's happen so far, always choose that action.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Right, so this possibly can't
work. It's going to violate the Q-learning convergence
that says we have to visit each state action pair infinitely often, and update
them to converge and you know and, and it makes perfect sense. Like if
we never try something, like how do you know that you don't like something
if you've never even tried it.
>> Like spinach.
>> Exactly. Another idea would be to choose randomly.
And this seems kind of good and that we are going
to visit. You know, all the states that are visitable
and we will try all the actions that are actionable.
And we could actually learn Q this way. But, as
you pointed out, this is not a great idea because
we may have learned Q, but we haven't really used
it. We haven't really chosen actions using what we've learned,
so it's like we're wise but we are impotent.
>> No, I think it's more like we're wise but we're stupid. I mean.
>> We're wise but we still. We know a
lot but refuse to actually do anything about it.
>> Right. In particular in some sense the only difference between the two
is the the theorem, right? If I, if I'm just choosing randomly. Wha, what's
the problem with them always choosing a
sub 0. Well, you're don't going to converge
but the real problem is that you don't learn anything. Or you don't take
advantage of anything you learned. Choosing randomly is basically the same
thing, you basically, you never take advantage of anything that you learn.
What's the point in learning a Q function if you are always
going to behave randomly, you've learned enough
or you've learned but you [CROSSTALK].
>> [CROSSTALK] right you've actually learned the ultra policy but you're
not following it so you're not actually using what you know,
so you can't you know it doesn't, it doesn't work all
right. So then you had another idea. Which was to use
our estimate to choose actions.
>> Yeah.
>> And that seems like a good idea in that
we will use it. Is it possible that it won't learn?
>> Well, it will learn something.
>> Well, yeah. It might not learn anything all that good though.
So for example, what if we do something like this. So we
initialize, now we're back up to this, this first point here. We
initialize the, the estimate Q hat so that for every state, a0 looks
awesome and all the other actions look terrible.
>> Wait [INAUDIBLE] is that metric awesome? Or English awesome?
>> Oh you're right I'm sorry, I didn't
put units on that. That's in Chilean dollars.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Oh okay, so it's pretty awesome then. Okay. So, if
you do that, then well let's see what happens. It's almost
like always taking a0. The only thing that would save you
from taking a0 forever, is if, as you take a0, you learn
that, you update your Qs and you keep getting really, really
bad results. Really, really bad results, in fact, worse than terrible.
>> yes. Well let's imagine the terrible is worse than terrible.
>> Oh.
>> So, but you're right, yeah you're right. So, so there's, there's
at least the case that if this, if this terrible value is
actually lower than the value of always choosing a0, then we'll continue
to use a0 forever. This is, this is called the greedy action
selection strategy.
>> Mm-mh.
>> And that, this is the problem that runs into, it's a kind of local min.
>> Oh, I see. Oh and oh, okay, I see that. So, you, you didn't even have
to come up with this ridiculous example. If
you, if you well, not ridiculous, but you, extremely.
>> I was going to say, I'm, I'm sorry, ridiculous how?
>> Well, I'm sorry. It, it's a ridiculous situation
to be in. It's sort of the extremely unluicky example.
>> I think what you're saying is
that you don't like people from Chile.
>> [LAUGH] Oh no I love people from, I love
Chile. Especially with you know, just some good beans and some
nice meat. But the thing is that you, if you randomly
set your Q hat in such a way that a bad
action or let's say a suboptimal action ends up looking much
better to begin with then the optimal action. You can get
in a situation where you keep choosing the wrong action anyway
and so you are only going to learn things that reinforce that
action which might be good just not optimal. So you won't actually end up
converging onto the true Q hat and that's why you get into a local min.
>> That's right and so in that bad situation and you,
I admit it's a little contrived because I've never, I've never even
been to Chile is that it wont learn. It'd actually be
exactly the same as this first case, always choose a sub 0.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, that seems problematic too and it interacts in an interesting
way with the initialization. Right. So maybe we can do this idea of using
Q hat, but we have to be much more careful about how we initialize.
>> Hm. So, you know, what I want to do is something like random restarts.